هذا وتتعدد قدره الصين على مساعده روسيا
بعيدا عن تزويدها بالاسلحه فمثلا تجاره
الصين مع روسيا اخذه في النمو حيث ارتفعت
في الربع الاول من العام بنسبه 28% عن
العام السابق وفقا لبيانات الجمارك
الصينيه وقد شكلت الصين حواليه 18% من
اجماليه تجاره روسيا في عام 2021 اي ما
يعادل 147 مليار دولار
اما بالنسبه للطاقه الروسيه فالصين واحده
من اكبر اسواق النفط والغاز والفحم الروسي
مع صفقات نفط وغاز روسيه جديده مع الصين
تقدر قيمتها بنحو
117.5 مليار دولار
عسكريا اعتمدت الصين بشكل كبير على
المعدات العسكريه الروسيه لتحديث قواتها
المسلحه فحوالي 80% من اجمالي واردات
الصين من الاسلحه بين عامي 2017 و2021
كانت من روسيا وفقا لمعهد ستوكهولم الدولي
لابحاث السلام
ماليا ما تزال تجاره الطاقه بين البلدين
تتم في الغالب بالدولار الامريكي ولكن
هناك تقارير تشير الى استخدام العديد من
الشركات الصينيه اليوان لشراء الفحم
والنفط الروسي في شهر مارس
غذائيا تعتبر الصين مستوردا رئيسيا للحبوب
مثل القمح والشعير ومن اهم مصادرها روسيا
التي تعد واحده من اكبر المنتجين في
العالم